[Music]
they begin by taking detailed
measurements of the athlete as she sits
in a demo chair they measure the width
and height of her knees to determine the
best seating position they check the
balance point to decide how the rear
wheel axles should be positioned and
they measure her arms so push rims can
be sized for her they then produce a
digital drawing of the racing wheelchair
complete with any extras requested by
the athlete the fabricator selects the
appropriate aluminum tubing and cuts it
to the desired length this one will be
the main tube for the racing chairs
frame rollers curved the tube slightly
at one end so the framework will
accommodate the seat a press then
flattens the tube quite a bit this
stiffens the metal and will make the
racing chair frame more aerodynamic
he now tapes a steering mechanism for
the front wheel onto the framework and
confirms that its placement is exact
before welding this device will keep the
front wheel on autopilot freeing the
racers hands to push the rear wheels the
welder now positions the other end of
the main tube perpendicular to the wheel
axle he welds the axle to the main tube
giving the framework a tee profile then
a hydraulic machine bends an aluminum
tube until we you shade to make the
racing chair seat frame
he positions the seat frame on the rear
axle and does a few more welds finally
he installs fenders on the wheels the
main framework of this racing wheelchair
is complete but to make it look flashy
they spray painted red this is a powder
coating
it's a thermoplastic paint that's
tougher than the conventional kind next
this machine rolls the push rims which
the athlete uses to propel the
wheelchair they weld on pegs for
attaching the rims to the wheels
then glue rubber sleeve onto each rim
they wrap it in tape to clamp the two as
the glue dries the tape stays on until
the chair is delivered to the customer
they install the rear wheels at an angle
to make the racing chair more stable
when cornering they add padding for the
athlete's knees then assemble the nylon
seat to the chair
next comes the front wheel steering fork
and handle
[Music]
they complete the assembly with the
spring-loaded cylinder that's part of
the steering autopilot system after
testing the steering fork they install
the front wheel which is smaller than
the rear - once it's been equipped with
brakes this custom racing chair is ready
to take on the competition an elite
athlete will buy a new racing chair
every year some choose rear wheels made
of lightweight carbon-fiber because any
advantage is welcomed in the push to win
[Music]